[Musik]
hey leute heute ist der tag der tage
heute mache ich burger bands und danach
und natürlich auch noch ein video zu
verschiedensten burger kreationen aber
ich glaube bürger bands ist das meist an
gefragteste rezept wirklich also seit
ungefähr zwei jahren fragte mich weil
die die mich auch auf instagram und
facebook verfolgen die wissen dass sich
bürger über alles liebe und in meiner
freizeit super gerne burger essen gibt
jetzt will ich euch gar nicht lange
hinhalten haben sie freut sich heute
auch schon total auf den tag dass es
heute zu hause bürger gibt ich zeige
euch jetzt mal die zutaten und zwar
benötigen wir ja natürlich sesam salz
frische hefe und braunen zucker
hier habe ich mir das ist weizenmehl das
550 er das ist ganz wichtig außerdem
butter hier habe ich noch milch und
wasser und wir gehen jetzt direkt an die
zubereitung für ihn für unseren vorteil
wir machen nämlich erst ein vorteil und
da machen wir einen richtigen hefeteig
und da gehen wir jetzt einmal über zum
herd und wir machen ja heute brioche
burger bands hat das gefühl die sind in
letzter zeit so ein bisschen mehr
entkommen
ihr könnt natürlich bestimmt auch die
normale bürger bans variante das
weißbrot mit sesam mir persönlich
schmeckt die brioche burger bank
variante viel viel viel besser und ich
mache auch nur die und ich bestell auch
nur die wenn ich draußen burger essen
sagt zeige ich euch die jetzt gegeben
jetzt zuallererst die butter zusammen
mit etwas wasser und milch in unseren
topf und da gebe ich dann auch schon das
mit hinzu
und jetzt verrät ihr das miteinander ich
habe den herrn jetzt auch schon
eingeschaltet denkt bitte daran ganz
ganz wichtig schaltet den nicht zu hoch
ich habe zum beispiel in neun stufen
neben der stufe 5 jetzt verrückt dass so
lange bis die butter verschmitzt alles
miteinander verbunden ist dann lasst ihr
das drei bis vier minuten waren so ganz
leicht küchen das zeige ich euch aber
gleich noch dann bilden sich nämlich
keine blase
nachdem wir den vorteig dann im topf
drei minuten hat köcheln lassen einmal
umfallen und jetzt vollständig auskühlen
lassen und dann machen wir weiter mit
dem restlichen teig das ist der vorteil
abgekühlt und es ist auch ganz wichtig
dass ihr bei diesem rezept alle schritte
beachtet und vor allem alles schön ab
weg denn dann kann ich euch garantieren
dass die perfekten bürgerbüro spannend
jetzt habe ich hier meine große schüssel
bereitgelegt gibt lauwarme milch an ganz
wichtig bei der arbeit mit hilfe immer
lauwarme milch verwendung auch nicht zu
heiß sonst steht die hilfe ab dann wird
ist auch nicht so schön
und da bröselig jetzt die frische hefe
hinein und gibt auch noch zucker mit
hinzu und verräters
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich auch direkt ohne
wartezeit drei und dem vortag dazu
gegeben ich gebe zu dass ich ein
bisschen komisch aus wenn man den
vorteil in die flüssigkeit gibt und wenn
man dann ungerührt dann entstehen auch
kleine klümpchen das ist aber völlig
normal und wichtig ist ja nur das
endergebnis und als nächstes nachdem ihr
das gut verrührt habt gebt ihr euer mail
mit hinzu und auch das salz und hier ist
auch ganz wichtig normalerweise mache
ich das so bei hefe zeigen da geb ich
einfach mehr nach gefühl dazu ich schaue
einfach ganz schön geschmeidig ist bei
diesem rezept bitte ganz genau abwiegen
und nicht mehr dazu tun und wenn es mit
dem schneebesen nicht weiter geht dann
ganz einfach die ärmel hochkrempeln und
mit den händen weitermachen
ich kannte den teig gibt auf der
arbeitsfläche weiter und ihr werdet
merken das ist ein relativ klebriger tag
aber verwendet trotzdem bitte nicht mehr
von dem mehl also 310 gramm es wirklich
die obergrenze danach erschoss falls ihr
das gefühl haben solltet ihr braucht
noch so ein bisschen was weil der teig
wirklich sehr klebrig ist dann nimmt
noch ein bisschen neutrales öl zum
beispiel hier das sonnenblumenöl und da
könnt ihr euch dann die hände mit allen
räumen und weiter kneten aber hiervon
auch nicht mehr als ein teelöffel alle
allerhöchstens nehmen und dann den teig
ganze fünf bis zehn minuten lang weiter
kneten mein tag ist jetzt richtig schön
geschmeidig und ihr könnt das jetzt noch
zu einer kugel formen
es geht da wie von alleine und dann
zurück in eine schüssel geben die
schüssel habe ich hier auch ganz leicht
ausgeschüttet ein grieche später besser
raus die hände sind ja noch ein bisschen
fertig also schön die kugel damit
benetzen und jetzt ein küchentuch
obendrüber legen und 60 minuten lang an
einem warmen ort gehen lassen wichtig
ist dass es an diesem ort nicht sieht
dann hat es der hefeteig nämlich am
liebsten und dann sehen wir uns gleich
wieder die stunde ist rum und der teig
ist wunderbar aufgegangen und das was
wir als nächstes machen ist ganz einfach
zu kugeln formen
ich mache das jetzt so dass ich eine
kugel immer abhängige das sollte dann so
ungefähr 120 gramm wiegen und dann
bekommt ihr fünf kugeln bzw
burger brioche ganz raus
[Musik]
ich zeige euch jetzt um die kugeln
formen könnte das gebe ich jetzt auch
mal mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
mit etwas abstand und so sieht ja noch
ein bisschen wärmer aus also ganz
komisch jetzt nimmt ihr euch einfach
immer den teig und schiebt den hierzu
mitte so lange bis die kugel schön rund
ist
[Musik]
und jetzt die fertig geformten bands
nochmal abdecken mit einem küchentuch
und dann lass dir das ganze noch mal 30
minuten gehen und dann kommt zum finalen
schritt ihr wir das in den backofen
schieben bis gleich unsere band sind
noch mal richtig schön aufgegangen und
jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere finger und
drücken sie einfach nur noch ganz leicht
flach und nur so ganz leicht also keinen
großen druck ausüben und als nächstes
brauchen unsere brio spannend ja noch
ein bisschen farbe und dafür nehmen wir
uns jetzt einige und so einen guten
teelöffel milch und zu quälen das
miteinander
[Musik]
und nachdem ihr euren zeigt dann mit der
mischung bestrichen haben fehlt nur noch
eine ganz ganz besondere zutat ganz
typisch für burger brötchen nämlich
sesam und den gebe ich es einfach nach
oben drüber
[Musik]
und die jetzt meine lieben kommen die
bürgerbräu schwanz in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 220 grad ober und
unterhitze für circa zwölf minuten und
danach können wir so weiter verarbeiten
[Musik]
nach dem backen könnt ihr eure burger
breher spanz beliebig weiterverarbeitet
es gibt 1000 und eine möglichkeiten
irgendetwas daraus zu basteln ob es
jetzt einen burger ist mit
karamellisierten zwiebeln so wie wir ihn
heute machen oder eben irgendwas anderes
patti smith verlaufe mit auch alles
mögliche es gibt noch so viele varianten
wie ich euch alle mit der zeit zeigen
werden und ich freue mich darauf dass
seit 1 basic rezept und dann werden nach
und nach immer wieder tolle kreationen
folgen jetzt seid ihr gefragt schreibt
mir mal in die kommentare was ist eure
liebste bürger kombination
ich bin super super super gespannt meine
filme ich hier im anschluss ab die kommt
dann auch demnächst auf einem kanal
online und ihr könnt die ganzen zutaten
jetzt hier unten in der infobox einmal
nachschauen
screenshot und einkaufen gehen und das
ganze dann nach backen wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann hinterlasst mir
auf jeden fall einen daumen nach oben
abonniert main kanal kostenlos und dann
freue ich mich wenn wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal wieder sehen ob die skizzen
tschüss